[Applause]
on the drive
Robert Williams good offensive rebound
Mark
Tatum iris again well defended but Tatum
just better
he can do that all night long all
afternoon long
Tatum drives Tatum finishes he can do
that
nothing right back on Tatum native gets
inside
Drake all over him hard up top round
thought about it Tucker came out
Tatum drives on Harris left-handed wins
it up and in that's spectacular move
jab step after jab step the spin move
the drive the left
oh what a sweet move from Jason Tatum a
little something scored by three
how about six of Celtics we're used to
Legends making plays Tatum putting his
name on the list
will do seven three pounds averaging
over 10 rebounds a game in these
playoffs
Tatum stops on a dime pulls up jumpers
and now he has the defense on his heels
a little brush screen now it's one on
one no help in the middle of the floor
smaller Mountain defending
[Music]
both number one picks for that team for
their teams
contain them gets inside close it up and
in
Harris Baldwin aisle but Tatum gets it
space side three
five points for Jason Tatum
look at this move in and out step back
Rhythm jumping he's clicking on all
cylinders in this first half
wow
sparked with seven to shoot into the
hands of Tatum and beat on him shot
clock winding down Tatum off the bounce
gets inside and packs it in as a shot
clock expired make a play doesn't settle
at the three-point line puts his head
down and attacks Mama there goes that
man
Tatum finding some space
swerving around and B
[Music]
step out three-pointer got it
he's got 30 already
allow me to have this dance one on one
loves you to sleep knock down three
Tatum's been Unstoppable
back another three punch him in Jason
Taylor the scorching right now the
previous play to me at some point
jumping switch is is doing Taylor a
favor a favor you switch it elevates
knocks down the shot some point double
teaming them and force him to get rid of
a lot of elite individual Defenders
[Applause]
Jason Tatum putting on an absolute
Clinic
sixer Celtics robbery playoff history
another name has entered the building
bad man he's got Nelson items between
the legs sidestep puts up another three
but Tatum tornado continues he's got 41.
in the field five of seven from downtown
and 10 rebounds as well
that takes all the pressure
Tatum Drive goes inside lays it up and
ends
it's up to 44.
again putting him beat into pick and
roll action and they're going to
challenge he wasn't a finalist that was
in The Joker
finished fourth overall
lays that one up and in
the third quarter
outscored 33-10
Tatum fires away
51 for Jason Tatum
again gets the preferred matchup that's
asking B to do a lot you know the rules
hand down man down and then holds up the
50 piece